a family doctor in a local
doctor's surgery located in melbourne
has been a practicing doctor for 30
years
yesterday he was raided by the
department of health and human services
or the dhhs
by seven
officials
um
he was rated um
it was shared on the mainstream media it
has also been shared on an independent
um
[Music]
journalist site an independent
journalist was actually present to film
the whole scenario
as they raided him they said it was due
to him
giving out exemptions to people
like myself
i have never seen this doctor however
given everything going on
i had multiple people including my legal
representative say to me
go and find a new gp who will grant you
the exemption again your case being
clear-cut
me feeling as though as well
i do have an extensive history it's not
as simple as me just finding a gp and
having a 10 minute consultation
um
someone had actually mentioned to me
this doctor may be able to help me
um
the person actually that gave me the
contact number was someone in a
political party in australia
um when i phoned his receptionist i was
told he's not accepting new patients and
that is fair enough that has been said
for quite a few doctors
so
um i just left it at that
yesterday i found out via the news that
this exact doctor had been raided by the
dhhs
what they had done
they have taken
all the private patient documents
all of their health records they have
seized them they have seized his log
books for his
um
for any of his appointments in his
appointment book
they were harassing his receptionist
asking what her vaccination status was
um
and
he is not allowed to practice
at the moment due to this and this all
eventuated yesterday
wow now obviously there could be
something about this doctor's story that
that you don't know there could be
something that justifies that kind of
intervention on the other hand it
certainly does seem consistent with the
world in which
i certainly know uh
here in the u.s that doctors
who uh are alarmed by the adverse event
signal associated with the vaccines
um are under
uh intense pressure
to do things that do not seem to be
in their
correct medical judgment
so
you know there's
there's also the possibility that this
is just simply authoritarianism
marching through your medical structure
and
punishing
and
blocking the action
of doctors who
are using their own judgment and
deciding who needs an exemption which is
of course exactly what you would want a
doctor to do to evaluate an individual
case and say yes this person needs an
exemption that person doesn't need an
exemption that's that's the system
functioning and here
uh it may well have triggered a raid and
the capturing of
private citizens medical files by the
government
so i guess that that brings us to
the question you know i i certainly hope
that this
broadcast
reaches whoever needs to be reached in
australia and that the sheer
embarrassment of your terrifying story
causes at the very least
your individual case to be resolved in a
way that protects your health as best we
can collectively do so
i also hope that anyone else who needs
an exemption
finds one because this story causes
the the necessary discretion to be
restored to the system so that it does
not generate tragedy after tragedy and
podcast after podcast about terrifying
losses of the ability to earn
uh for example and just for starters i
mean really at some level
you are being
placed in a predicament
where
your livelihood will be lost if you do
not accept a vaccination that puts your
life in jeopardy
and
if you
[Music]
do not take this life jeopardizing
vaccination
you lose
a substantial fraction of your natural
rights as a citizen
your right to move about freely
your right to earn a living
you become a partial prisoner in your
home
and
that is simply
perfectly inconsistent with the rights
that the founders of the western way of
life
uh recognized you have the right to live
normally and there's nothing
about this pandemic
that justifies this level of
authoritarianism
and to have this level of
authoritarianism
pushing
vaccines of such low quality
and such dubious safety
especially pushing them towards somebody
with such vulnerability really reveals
the entire problem
the system is absolutely out of control
we citizens don't know what it's about
but we can tell from your story and many
others that we are dealing with customer
service we are not dealing with a public
health apparatus we are not dealing with
government in any normal sense we are
dealing with customer service which
wishes to deny us something and will
give us every excuse in the book in
order to do so
and
i
i
i did not think we would ever find
ourselves here i mean just think about
the
the fact of us having this discussion
um
across you know across a diagonal over
the pacific ocean
that we should have to talk about
the failure of the west because nothing
else captures a failure that stretches
from australia to north america
to europe
it's it's remarkable and
uh
i i wish i wish i knew what it was we
were supposed to do next i do have the
sense that many people
died to provide us the liberties that we
are now losing and that that is supposed
to be capturing our attention in a way
that it has not yet
yeah it feels quite surreal especially
when um
poland was even offering
that it's dual citizens
who were living in victoria essentially
refuge over in poland to get out of our
state
due to what is going on over here
when we're having
the
you know
the the polish embassy saying things
like that
it's what have we become as
you know a first world westernized
country where our citizens are needing
to seek refuge elsewhere
because our home state is illivable
this is this is terrifying um
as as a jew i'm 52 years old
when i was a kid
the holocaust seemed like ancient
history i of course now as an adult know
that it was not that it was very recent
but i certainly
was led to understand by my elders my
elders who had seen the holocaust
that it could happen anywhere and that
one needed to be alert to the fact that
this authoritarian menace
can emerge that this is a defect in the
human psyche and the fact that things
seem
uh to be humming along at one moment
does not mean that you don't need to be
aware of the possibility because it can
emerge at any time
what no one
ever alerted me to and what i think
no one ever contemplated
was that it could happen everywhere at
once
that's a terrifying possibility and
i am
struck by the fact that australia
is certainly one of the places that
would have been highest on my list of
places to run to
if my own country had ever
done this
i am now watching
i know two people personally one an
individual and one
the father of a
family who are literally
fleeing australia they've sold what they
have and they are doing everything in
their power to get out
because the authoritarian and
authoritarianism
is
clearly advancing and nobody knows where
it stops
i don't know what it's going to take
to wake us up but i think the fact is
this isn't exactly what we were warned
about but it's clearly a close relative
of it
[Music]